in a middle management position what's
the best way to support the company and
leadership you work for while still
showing your fellow workers they are
supported and appreciated I work in
surgery at a large hospital with an even
larger corporation this is one of those
things I remember saying I'm sure I got
this from Hackworth but it's one of
those things that I've said so many
times I actually probably forget to even
give credit to Acworth but you know when
problems little problems will arise up
the chain of command and I'd be like
everyone hates the echelon of command
above them right that's the way it is
like and that's just the way it is
that's the way it is it's always they
don't get it it's always they don't
understand unless you get somebody that
really knows how to explain and
communicate down the chain of command so
that everyone understands why they're
doing what they're doing that's what
this is that's exactly what this is like
what's the best way to support the
company leadership it's to take what the
company and the leadership of a company
says and translate it to the troops in a
way that they understand and that means
something to them right so you go to a
big meeting and you know like let's say
an all-hands meeting for a company and
and the CEO is saying hey we made you
know we made 87 million dollars last
year profit and if all the frontline
troops are in there they're like well
that's cool but I didn't see any that
reflected him my paycheck by the way you
gave me a $4 raise over the last three
years how about some of that 87 million
kick it down to the people so that's
problematic because we aren't explaining
hey good that's it that literally that
statement right there will actually make
people mad the the CEOs thinking
everyone's gonna love me because I'm
telling them how profitable we are as a
company all everyone's thinking isn't
well then why can't you afford to buy me
that piece of gear that we need on the
frontlines what's your problem
that's so you actually think you're
helping but you're actually hurting
unless you can explain to people look we
made this much profit here's how it's
gonna benefit us as a company and you as
a frontline troop by us making this much
it means we can grow these areas it
means we can bring on more people that
means everyone in this room right now in
the next three years you're gonna have
an opportunity to be in a leadership
position that's what I'm talking about
that's why we're trying to grow that's
why we're trying to do better by the way
as we this is snowball and even more
because now we're putting more money
into advertising we've got a whole
advertising campaign that's going on
we've invested a bunch of money in that
and it's gonna bring us more business
and that means the jobs that you think
might not be stable your job if you
don't think it's stable it just got
stable because we have the capital to
get this machine moving even faster so
when you do that when you explain to the
troops why something's happening it
makes them understand and it shows your
people hey you're supporting are there
times where you should push back yes
there are and if something makes no
sense whatsoever you should raise your
hand and say hey let me go let me run
this up the chain of command let me run
this up the chain of command and explain
why this isn't a good idea and that way
you can go and when you get the reason
because there'll be a reason and it
might not be the best reason but it'll
be a reason and you go back to church
and say hey here's why this is going on
this is what's happening this is the
decision they made and you know what
we're gonna do our best to execute it
because that's what we do we make things
happen we're gonna get it done boom and
we get a great we've got a great
depiction of that in that talking about
being humble not passive and pushing
back where it matters in the dichotomy
leadership that's that whole section is
talking exactly about that it's a very
hard thing for people and that the basis
of this question though is the US versus
them right front lines versus corporate
headquarters and and you've got to
defeat that if you're a good leader you
got to recognize look we're all on the
same team we can't do what we need to do
without having the support and you know
the resources and the approvals of plans
from the corporate headquarters you know
and in a corporate headquarters that
often times so not only are is there
frustration up the chain there's also
frustration down the chain you hear that
all the time like will the frontlines
they don't really get it you don't get
it over there well listen from the
frontlines is where the actual mission
gets won or lost yeah so you've got a
you might want to have them on board
with the process so you got to make sure
that you know that
got to if you want a successful team you
can't have us versus him ever twice and
a big win for the big yeah The Full
Metal Jacket right what's your problem
son why don't you get on board for the
big win and and you think oh well if I'm
the general and I'm telling this young
guy that's got a peace sign on his
helmet that represents the dichotomy
maybe that's where I learned the word
dichotomy from that represents the
dichotomy of what does he say the
dichotomy he says the duality of duality
of man yeah you're right that represents
the duality of man why don't you take
that thing off and get on board for the
big win and that's such a great line
from that moon join the team son get on
board for the big one that's such a
great line from that movie because
that's exactly what we're talking about
that does absolutely nothing for that
front line soldier that goes okay you're
saying that and I'm literally burying
people right now in this situation and
so for you saying that's me means
nothing in fact it shows how completely
freaking out a touch you are and so they
did a great job in that movie of
representing that through one single
line it why don't you just get on board
for the big win it's like well no
actually why don't you lead how does
that sound
so communicate up and down the chain of
command make sure people know why and
tie-in or why it matters to them